it's a hell of a lot better to try to
become liked because you're helping
another human then because you bought
Gucci loafers everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is it this is
episode 300 of the askgaryvee show Scott
and I'm very excited I made a big to-do
and told them we gotta save this slot
it's gonna be this big 300 and they make
that movie about that exactly the
warrior yes Gary me show I think this is
super special hey you've been on the
show before and B I think what better
you know what better slot to use then
for somebody I admire who's on a project
that I admire and so for the
vaynernation who's watching why don't
you tell them who you are and what
you're doing here on this special day
I'm happy to come up to you this time
thank you so twelve years ago started an
organization called charity water very
simple mission bring clean drinking
water a name and your name oh yeah sorry
Scott Harrison yeah want to help get
every single person on earth clean
drinking water and been at that now for
12 years love what you've been saying
lately about you know showing up for you
know not a year or nine months or nine
weeks right it's been it's really been
twelve years of really really hard work
and that's the mission to get everybody
clean water then the vision is really to
reinvent charity and you and I have
talked about this over the years so many
people don't trust charity so many
people aren't giving there's a cynicism
there's a skepticism and we just tried
to design the perfect charity what would
people want to give to what would it
feel like how would we handle their
money what would those feedback looks
loops look like so it's been twelve
years of trying to innovate in that
direction as well and you know I'm
hopeful that this has hit your radar
because I probably bring it up once a
month or even if you're not cynical or
you don't think about giving and you
come from a good place you were brought
up the way I was which is you know
society that like you know you worked
hard your whole life and then you got
older and then you started giving away
money like that was just my framework
when you
me and Chris Sacca were in the basement
of that bar in meatpacking district you
I always say this cuz I think I do this
a lot for my employees and other people
sometimes one sentence just clicks in
the right way you look me dead in the
face and you're like you're a good dude
I you know you did your intuition thing
like I think you're a good dude and like
you're just gonna do the cliche thing
and like why not give now and I'm like
why not give now like no different
that's like all those clips I put on
Instagram where I'm like or you could
quit your job
and I never you know and the person's
like I can quit my job and then
everybody in the comments like he's
[ __ ] speaking common sense he doesn't
say anything that profound what the [ __ ]
you didn't say anything so crazy you
just said to me or you could start
giving now ya know and I thought it
would be fun I mean why would you
deprive yourself of the fun of being
able to use your time and your talent
your money to get involved with a bunch
of great causes and see that impact now
see organizations grow I mean we've been
working for you know ten years like the
very beginning I know we're big omaha
right there was no charity water it was
like an idea we might have gotten a few
hundred thousand people clean water and
yeah we've now been friends ten years
and that number is about to be ten
million people with clean water at the
end of this year and you know I know
please it Souls like you've seen you
know you've seen the impact of both
money and you know it evolves I
apologize for interrupting like I think
one of the things for everybody watching
somebody asked me they said their day
and I've never really said this public
I'm gonna use it as his framework
because I am kind of quiet about the
good things I do it's interesting
obviously I'm gonna boorda pencils of
promise
obviously charity water well member
obviously spent a lot of time in the
Crohn's and Colitis foundation because I
AJ done good amount with autism and
things of that nature because of Matt
Higgins my part but it's been
interesting the evolution is fascinating
one of the things that's really evolved
with me in 2018 and 17 is giving to
people I kind of know so one of the
things that's really struck me you know
much like I think about micro
influencers and call Youm content at
scale one of the things in my giving
life that has hit me more is these gives
when it's you know you know one thing
that you know everybody says getting
older one of the real not fun things as
things start happening and just people
that I've shared that you know I'm just
thinking about something right now
somebody hit me up just cold DM on
Twitter luckily I was just scrolling
through which I don't
as much as I do on Instagram and she's
like look I know this woman I've seen
her seven or ten times in Business
keynote speak she's things of that
nature and she's like I'm sick and I've
got this go fund me and like it wasn't
even the hesitation
mm-hmm and it felt great mmm because the
context is there it's not as much as
given to a big war which big mission
your mission is so the most fun I mean
when you know by the way I talk a lot at
these days about perspective boy has
being involved helped me in like use
real life analogies of like yes I
understand you're very upset that your
stock went down today let me tell you
about people that walk 7 hours to get
cleaner and you know you know what's
great about water there's always water
I'm always like you know how you're
devastated right now you know that
bottle you're always pointing to you
have that you could go to the sink right
now there are literally people who walk
5 6 7 8 hours through dangerous
situations whether it's just getting
hurt or getting robbed or it's just
people lack perspective yeah two things
that I was thinking of you know one I
believe people give to people not causes
most people give to people so even if
you look at our fundraising movement
it's like the nine year old kids
donating their birthday the 35 year olds
or how or how do you build carry the
original pillars of this I gave to you
it's and to it through you to them yeah
and and someone said to me once I said
look I get to support all these causes I
get to live he said it's God I get to
live vicariously through you I can't go
to 69 countries like you I can't go to
Ethiopia 30 times but I feel like I'm
living vicariously through your work
like you're the conduit for me to this
issue and this person was supporting a
bunch of other causes he starts listing
all he's like this is a great joy to me
that I am do I'm a part of this work
around the world work here domestically
work internationally and I'm able to do
that
you know with my money the other thing
I've I was just thinking of because it
seems like you've really found the joy
of giving these days I believe the more
you give the more you give when you like
you just you get almost addicted to the
generosity well I'll be honest with you
the thing that clearly is more you know
and this is probably my biggest
with you and I've been able to get in
the field with pop way more than I have
a charity water through many different
reasons but I you know to me giving
money you know you know one of the
things that I want to do more of
specifically with charity wilderness is
kind of like I've done a good job on
using my platform to continue to bring
you exposure you know and we're here
about yeah but people house cover sir
but but I want to do more actually you
know the thing that I'm most addicted to
is is getting feedback loop of people
that right now I'm completely and
utterly addicted to the fact that I
started pushing garage sale culture and
we talked about it before we went on
look there's no hi bigger for me than
the thousands we're now into the tens of
thousands of comments that I'm getting
in DM you see the public ones if you
follow me heavy the retweets of people's
eBay accounts that I love doing almost
every day that's how I got started
though remember I sold two thousand DVDs
on eBay whole city for the mers then I
went out to yard sales I was selling I
was telling these guys I found like
lecture osanic mics I was putting up
every single thing I could to fund the
two years on the mercy ships and then
yeah I'm late in my life for everybody
watching we're gonna link up the prior
episode if you want to ask God a
question let me and for knowing my
audience a please ask about nonprofits
charity water but listen let's call it
what it is and I want my doesn't need to
be nonprofit and I you and I that's
right and I think where I really want to
go is like look we're not gonna go into
you can watch a prior episode which we
did of askgaryvee at charity water and
we'll link that here we'll figure out
what episode number that was where you
can get a lot of the origin so I don't
think he swore once and then entire that
true it was amazing
I had this effect on you always have a
good effect on me speaking of which
those swearing good effects bad effects
like all those things look Scott was a
wildly successful club promoter all the
vices that would get everybody excited
about he always puts in his spiel I
always loved his first three minutes I
mainly like watching other young people
he watched their faces when I've heard
it so many times then the last 20 times
I've been in a room with Scott whether
if I'm watching everybody else because
he's talking about like models and like
champagne and like exotic stuff and I'm
like watching all the faces and it's
just so funny like the cliche like 20
year olds like but what really I
you know you're an unbelievable
marketing and brand mind I mean that's
the truth one of the biggest reasons
that I gravitated towards your
organization besides the transparency
and the dollars going to one of the
reasons I did the well which a real
substantial commitment was because it
allowed you to make every one of these
care everybody's watching right now if
they go to charity water and they donate
$5 or their birthday consists of 26
birthday you get $26 the fact that me
and how many individuals are now in the
well 131 families those 131 families
very special families by the way for
many different reasons who they are but
who they are not who they are I don't
know what the math works out these days
but that being able to subsidize the
overhead of the organization yeah so let
me talk about them I mean there's two
bank accounts for people that don't know
the organization two years ago we
basically I apologize I want to get this
if you have a question marketer your
networker Brander I want to talk about
the book that's what we're here right
and I'm so excited yeah people callin I
sent you one today messenger yeah we got
it somewhere Tyler I'm pretty proud of
it looks good as pictures and there's a
new book out when did it come out four
weeks four weeks so it was doing really
well which makes me excited at the time
hey I want everybody to pick up the book
we'll try to find and put it up here
below superimpose if not but if you have
a question for Scott please email Gary
Vee team at vaynermedia comm Gary Vee
team at vaynermedia comm ask your
question in the headline put your phone
number in the body ask your question in
the headline put your phone number in
the body Gary Vee at Maine Gary Vee team
at vaynermedia comm we'll get to some of
those questions meddlesome so go ahead
so you're you're supporting 131 people
pay for all the overhead 280 staff the
offices the flights all that stuff and
then over a million donors have gotten
this pure play we're a hundred percent
of their five bucks or five hundred
thousand goes directly out to the
projects so that's like that you know
you're in Lizzy support has been so
valuable in that way and and look we
just said
is why people aren't giving and there's
a lot of really smart people out there's
a guy called dan pelota gave a famous
TED talk you know raging against this
idea that big overheads are bad we're
like we believed in but that's an uphill
battle we're just gonna create a
different business model we're gonna go
find a hundred thirty one people the
founders of Facebook and Twitter and
Spotify and you know WordPress I mean a
bunch of you've got 50 friends in that
program and say hey help us pay for the
software engineers help us pay for the
phone bills and the epson copy machine
so that we can go out to millions of
people and say every single bit of your
donation will go and then we'll track it
and you know the last time we talked we
were just starting to put sensors on our
wells we now have 3,500 wells online we
have another 2,000 about to go online
and we're monitoring over a billion
liters look it's here
Wow two of them Tyler ones for you Tyler
one for you brother all right this is it
it was two years two years right and so
ya know look I think one of the things
that all the money goes I gave away the
advance I know you told me not to but I
think that I think that what's really
powerful about this story is when you
mark it in a contemporary way so much of
the content which you guys have been
continued building better and better
skills around build so much awareness so
much of under 35 has gravitated to an
organization like this and again even
look at the faces in this room if they
get inspired which many have time and
time and again and by the way Big Ups to
Instagram live who's watching now we're
on the askgaryvee show episode 300 Scott
Harrison the founder of charity:water
new book I want to make it up but more
importantly Instagram if you're watching
if you have a question for Scott as you
keep listening Gary Vee team thank you
Gary Vee team at vaynermedia comm ask
your question and the headline your
phone number in the body Gary Vee team
at vaynermedia comm put your question in
the headline phone number in the body
you know a lot of the people that are
watching now skew young knowing my
audience when you give $20 and so by the
way I know on the site you can you can
give up the birthday thing was huge yep
that was a birthday work that's it about
that was a million bucks that idea
created 60 million
and then some people donating yeah
running across man sir Henry's in
campaign sixty-five million with that
when do you turn 2.9 great so this way
yeah you're too long okay what's that
right fair enough whose clothes birthday
like me by the way my birthday is
literally Wednesday yeah when I turned
43 I'm gonna try to sell some wine
because I got 43 but but on my 44th
birthday when I want to give up 44
dollars for your 40 and what you do is
you create a page you ask all your
friends and acquaintances and relatives
don't to just donate 44 dollars to
charity water and that's the gift and if
you think about it works so many ways
over number one like it I like me my
whole family's been yelling all week
what do we get you I'm like don't give
me anything
give me a tax-deductible receipt so we
could get you know handbags wallets ties
gift cards or get people clean wanted
the idea was just to create this
movement of generosity around birthdays
right we we don't really need more stuff
and people don't even have clean water
six hundred sixty million people don't
have clean water since that one more
time to throw that number out tenth of
the planet one of every ten people right
now is drinking bad water so six hundred
sixty three million people and has gary
hours how many of those people live in
africa about a third and what a third in
india third in Southeast Asia
that's really where it's at a little bit
in Central and South America but I'd say
that some of the biggest margin just
because I'm watching the faces in this
room which is a face of i'ma computer
talk to me about bad water so Brown yeah
he's is in it help help I wish we did
almost cut in the images like it's you
know it's it's disgusting it's brown
viscous you know it's it's this image
yeah so you know I I photograph this
hero in Kenya drinking this water and
she would vomit on herself every time
she drank from this bottle so it was
this terrible cycle of disease and 52
percent of all the disease throughout
the developing world is caused by bad
water so half the sick people don't need
to be sick they just had clean water and
toilets and the women are walking like
you said six hours a day often forty
billion hours are wasted just by women
every year in Africa
water so is this huge problem it impacts
women it did max girls the girls are
dropping out of school because just
let's play it a little bit you know
right now the America you know when you
started this when when you hit my cuz I
let me go different way in two thousand
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen
when I was involved watching it gaining
momentum the the the atmosphere in
America was different mmm-hmm with the
political climate with the cultural
climate have you found it more difficult
in the last twelve months to get people
to care about this issue when a lot of
people have started really caring about
domestic issues race gender like like
fires in California yeah like just
watching our circle on Instagram this
weekend yeah I would say fifty percent
of the people that I saw talking about
and donating and doing stuff and we're
giving to that like you know we're doing
this I mean you and I personally not yes
we are yes but have you found over the
last eighteen months more of a challenge
for people to get excited about a girl
in Kenya during the current state of
vibes in America I'm just curious my
lord so the numbers would say no like
you forty percent last year I know but
you're on the pulse thoughts because I'm
I actually what think about getting
easier talk so stated okay so go so in
in perhaps the most toxic political
environment yeah that certainly of my
lifetime where people are angry people
hate each other this is something that
people can actually agree to agree on
interesting so I've got right-wing
Republican er I've got left-wing you
know Democrats yeah I've got Jews and
Christians and Muslims and atheists and
Mormons like Mormons are running hundred
thousand dollar campaigns you know
synagogues are sending in money Muslims
school kids during Ramadan and Dubai
like it's actually okay this thing that
people can say if we don't have clean
water right what have we got and we can
agree to agree on that so we've seen
growth in this toxic period interesting
and I think you know as well there is a
sense of like Americans want to be seen
as good neighbors we want to out stretch
our arms
across an ocean and end the suffering of
others and say we do care about you we
see you little girl we see the
conditions you were born into and we can
do something about I think we also have
now 12 years of building trust we praise
330 million dollars so we've got a third
of a billion dollars now through through
grassroots through the grassroots so we
now have you know GPS coordinates on the
wells we have sensors on the wells you
know we've stuck around I know that
you're talking about this like we've
stuck around long enough I get a man
that is like Oh charity water I just
thought about snot we've been at it for
over a decade I talk about this a lot
I'll tell you why when you are
charismatic like you are and listen
because this is almost me doing it for
my own self the amount of times that
people have had conversations and
dinners with me where they're like yeah
but what's he gonna do next
especially when you were so out in front
of it's the same thing with me because I
talk about my dream and ambition to buy
the New York Jets it people struggle
with realizing how good of a guy I am
because I think they can co-exist
because you talked about being you know
an a player in a New York City singing I
feel like and you're so young if I feel
like a lot of people are just waiting
for you to move on and do something else
well if they're waiting a long time
here's the way I look at it so the the
most common way that argument is
presented to me is why don't you go out
start a company make a ton of money I
know what take it public or you know I
think you all the money as if I'm so
talented okay first of all that's a big
assumption and then give the money away
and you know I normally say to them how
many people do you know that have given
a third of a billion dollars away okay
and then next year that's gonna be 450
million and then it's 560 and then it's
670 and then you know there's gonna be a
billion dollar number that has flowed
through my hands brother right I would
have to be like I wanted a I'd have to
be such an extraordinary people like
entrepreneur to go make that much money
that I'm then giving a billion and and
luck Gates has done it and Buffett has
done it but you know there's there are
you names is like 1834 people have done
right yeah we appreciate so it's but I
might be able to look back at some point
and act
we have billions of dollar course if I
continue to work hard you know build
this team invite people into the
movement give nine-year-old girls a
voice with their lemonade stands
I mean we've you know you understand
like we have kids we their kids out
there there are four year olds that are
painting for charity water there's a
four-year-old named Cosette that sold
fifty one hundred dollars of paintings
there's a nine year old in Vancouver
that did twelve lemonade stands one of
them was in the rain her mom's like
you're not selling lemonade in the rain
she's like no I am I'm staying out here
her last lemonade since she gets she
convinced a local band to perform it
next to the lemonade stand and she sells
fifty eight hundred dollars of lemonade
so we want to be that organization that
a is a little bit of a bomb maybe to the
toxic city of we hate each other we
disagree everything else like no let's
come together on generosity let's care
for others let's end suffering through a
basic need water is like it's not
political you know if I was building
schools undoubtedly there are people out
there saying what are they learning what
ideology are they learning right you
know are the teachers any good is their
quality water is a binary good it's
clean and it's flowing or it's not and I
think we've just tried to call people
into that and now we have you know over
a million people hopefully it's two
million and 3 million it's amazing now
proceeds to the book how does that all
that goes to the organization I'm not
making a penny so I turned over the
advance every every penny going forward
I wanted it to be pure I we talked about
this I don't feel like I could use the
organization but I also didn't want to
have you know it was supposed to be in
the kids college fund I mean that was
gonna be the initial idea but it's I
wanted to go far and wide and I wanted
to help a lot of people I wanted to
inspire social entrepreneurs you know
they're probably people listening that
have some issue that is not OK on their
watch Heath okay hello the Heath Heath
its Gary Vaynerchuk you're on the
askgaryvee show with Scott Harrison it's
up here you got to be kidding me that's
awesome
you made a brother what's your question
yeah first of all thanks for Scott kurz
talk in Phoenix what was it yesterday
man you're a man on the move so thanks
for that the entire yeah was yesterday
one of the Greek we have a lot of
connection in southern County New Jersey
just a lot of way we see the world but
no question like living in the airport
is also an equal connection for Scott
and I so I just got competitive he was
hustling so hard I can't wait to go to
places yeah go ahead yep so so super
inspired by the the story and the
innovation that Scott has brought to the
charity space I left the corporate world
at the end of the last year have been
putting in the ground work to start up a
charity myself kind of you know
mid-forties typical evolution when I
want to I know Scott doesn't like the
words give back but just yeah you know
let's give you want to give I want to
give so the question is we are in the
infancy stages of starting up a charity
for at-risk youth using Brazilian
Jujitsu the sport of Brazilian jiu-jitsu
as a vehicle to keep them out of gangs
away from drugs that sort of thing
I like a lot of the innovation that I've
seen you know your model in terms of
like 100 percent model yeah
storytelling is a foundation for
engaging donors and things like that so
obviously you've set the bar pretty high
in terms of you know things to implement
but what I'm interested in is given you
know my shoes right now of saying what
are the highest priority things that we
should focus on and there's a team of
about three or four of us right now
starting this up what are the things
that we should initially focus on to
hopefully scale this thing over the next
you know three to five years sure so two
things come to mind get your business
model around money down I don't think
you need to adopt the hundred percent
model it's incredibly difficult
hopefully I said this from stage I am
trying to tell people you know running
to effectively to organizations in
perfect balance at the same time is
incredibly challenging we're lucky to
have Gary and Lizzy and these other
families but there are I don't think you
need 100% model to be successful what I
think you need it's just to tell people
where their money goes we're open to a
of value propositions we just want to we
want clarity around where the dollars
went if you told us right now that your
greatest need was a lawyer to
incorporate you there are people that
are saying great I'll help you pay those
legal fees and I think the storytelling
like you've got to be out of the gate
telling stories of these youth of why
your solution is effective you know give
me give me stories that where it's
worked you know show me success stories
there was that there was that viral
video was Kony like the yeah the
Invisible Children guys yeah I mean that
was that was it has a lot of other
things that were going on I don't know
all the story so I'm gonna leave it that
but they did make much like the Dollar
Shave Club a signaler piece of you and I
have made it too we've we've got 12 or
13 million views with a spring now and
listen and I hired the Cody guys you and
I have a lot of videos that have gone
viral then there's that video and the
Dollar Shave Club which went to a
different level when you start getting
into tens and hundreds yeah you know
hundred yes things like the first
there's just a big difference we had a
hundred million in one week on a video
it's just like me and my personal simon
Sinek our friend like he's got like I'm
putting out like so where I'm going with
that brother is he there's like story
telling is it and what's amazing about
the Internet is you actually could be
like Scott and I and just put out a lot
of great stuff which in the collective
eventually creates something or you
could be like Dollar Shave Club boss
literally one video listen people try to
make a viral video every day of the week
500 today 9,000 people post it on
YouTube yeah something that cost four
hundred thousand dollars to make with
the hope that 100 million people would
watch it but the stories matter so much
I'll say one other thing
the reason Scott has a hundred fifty or
so families that are writing substantial
checks to under write the organization
is he leaned into self-awareness and a
personal skill he said as you know has
everybody who's watching as you saw on
stage as my little five person crew
that's sitting here and as I knew when
you have that level of charisma and
authenticity and a way to communicate
that touches somebody you have a chance
of being able to create that kind of
model when I hear some
say I'm cliche and I'm 40 and things
have gone well and I want to give back I
also say to myself huh he also knows
four to seven to 39 other people that he
came up with that also did well within
the industry on his team so I always
tell people lean into self-awareness and
strength it's good if you were to
position in your mid-40s where you can
afford to make this transition and just
hearing the way you deliver the sentence
I'm like let's keep it basic here oh
[ __ ] he knows other rich people right
and and if you make something called the
ring which is or the squared circle or
the [ __ ] octagon or another [ __ ] you
want to call it and there's eight people
in the octagon that launched this
charity with you and they all run two
hundred fifty thousand dollar checks cuz
they can well guess what you start
getting into a model so like people shy
away from their strengths sometimes
I wouldn't does that make sense he yeah
point well-taken and Gary I think this
question the the the final question that
I have I think you might be able to lend
some expertise here as well one of the
big light bulb moments when I was
studying Scott's youth case was his
transition from you know traditional
charities basically starting over at
zero every year in terms of their
fundraising yes and saying you know this
is the thing that almost made him quit
right because it's like this is never
ending business cycles we have a great
year and I can't Trump that so
transitioning to a recurring revenue
model yes big light bulb went on one
thing that I've been queuing around in
my brain is if we take that approach you
know what kind of content can we give
back so that when yes you know my credit
card expires and I'm Margo renew that
first of all the fact that's the right
question if you notice that we both
reacted the question already gives us
confidence let me throw one other thing
at you
yes content I will tell you right now
access the biggest thing that I think
people don't understand is how important
accesses as well so for example a lot of
what I've been thinking about is like
what if January 5th was the day like
what if like like there was a special
day like what can you do around that day
when everybody reoccurs for the year
I've been thinking a lot about like
Black Friday like it's this heavy
commerce day could it become this huge
giving day and then what do you do
around that week I think access I think
one thing that charity:water does
extremely well and one thing that I'm
actually gonna talk to Scott about off
camera and now I'm just gonna share it
on camera is I think of the big charity
water like ball event at the end of the
year and we've talked about we never
executed I like the we bring it up like
a smaller wine version I look at it like
Ted right Ted
had this incredibly big event in May
whoever is such a big deal and some
people argue diluted the brand which I
would argue is true but I think in other
ways that expanded the brand they
started creating TEDx right so to me
just even hearing what you're saying one
of the things you could do is have like
four major UFC events each year that
certain people get access to to go with
you and that's Saturday and that Sunday
morning is the bar to go with the kids
go to the coeds in the program there's
things you can access access like I'll
give you one if I started something like
this tomorrow the first thing I would do
is do a live call-in show every Friday
night from 4:00 to 6:00 because I'm good
at it and more importantly it's access
so I think access is something that
people gravitate towards to not just
content and as content continues to grow
it gets commoditized but access doesn't
the trips to the field community that's
the second piece so Heath with that with
our recurring Giving Program you know we
pivoted from the birthdays at year 10
over to the spring which is now it's
been growing it's up I think 277 percent
I mean it's it's crazy growth 104
countries you stop everybody I love when
people think things happen by accident
nobody talks in terms like 270's I think
like I just I mean I just want I want I
want people to understand what it takes
to be successful you don't say
277 I think 277 percent you don't say
300 you didn't say 250 like when you're
in your [ __ ] and you know it's 200
got on my phone right so you created
infrastructure to have a dashboard on
your phone like it means you're in it it
means you're thoughtful it you know you
know how you build these things brother
back to like you know why he didn't quit
you know why vaynermedia doesn't scare
me even though every scope ends every
year too it's when you're in your craft
it's when you're passionate about
something you're figuring it out you're
in the trenches you maybe we think
you're gonna be successful because the
data of you already was to get them into
this position but I want to say this
isn't me on a tangent this is why
passive income scares the [ __ ] out of me
all these kids get tricked into
recurring revenue and they think they're
gonna create a landing page and they're
gonna make money and people can just
keep paying them and they go to sleep
there is no recurring revenue there's
it's not in Lua you know doing other
fundraising efforts traditional
fundraising efforts I think Scott you
know used a good term which you said it
just evens out the peaks and valleys so
that they can better plan how they're
gonna scale you know over a three-year
timeframe as opposed to being reactive
yeah our recurring is only about right
now about 11 million out of 70 so but
the beautiful thing is when you have
that many people giving monthly so we've
got about 33,000 givers giving $30 a
month on average from 140 countries that
the halo effect on the whole
organization is huge so you can't help
but grow the other parts of it so there
was a I'll give an example there was a
woman Chicago that was given 30 bucks a
month I know for five or six months she
calls up the office she gives $50,000
builds five wells she got to know the
organization through that through the
content through the community we just
hosted an event in Atlanta where we just
invited 300 of our spring members just
to come and meet each other and to meet
some of the people in our water programs
team just building community so we threw
a party for people giving $30 a month so
y'all I think you'll figure that out the
content the community you know
connecting people and I think it's it's
got to be an important part of your
organization so I'm glad you're doing it
from the beginning I wish I had done
that from the beginning I felt like I
was ten years too late on that good luck
very appreciative of the model you could
look because it's an easy reflection
point to try to mimic some of the good
things you see she ate that
thank you better good luck man take care
good luck thank you I think it's Ryan I
think he's made a really important point
and again trying to make this valuable
for my audience like you know I always
talk about like watch what I do not what
I say like when you watch something you
can take that if you deploy multiple
layers if you watch what I do not what I
say if you deploy self-awareness and
know who you are you can look at a model
and then you can decide what you can and
can't do in that model and then you can
start hacking a lot of people can't be
on planes 270 100 days a year right it's
just not in their energy levels things
that nature but when you can see a
framework you can start chipping away
making it your own by the way that's
what you did from because you have so
many tech friends and so many tech
founders even recurring revenue streams
gets into Alexa yeah and I was talking
to people who I was talking to Danny
where I could Spotify about recurring
revenue like I was cuz he was helping to
pay a guy but he was helping to pay for
the overhead for six years you know like
so I think that was the community of
people that we put ourselves in I mean
charity water was not hanging out with
other nonprofits you know we were we
were reading Fast Company we were
reading Wired we were hanging out with
people who were innovating and trying to
learn from them and ask those those
questions when didn't you understand
that that was the next class feel like
you dug very deep into our world very
fast like what what made that happen
well it started with Michael birch it
started with that transformative million
dollar gift what 11 years ago after they
sold me Febo right after he sold bebo
and it's funny I just had I've had a
dinner in San Francisco this week and
Marissa Meyer was telling this story
about meeting me 11 years ago someone
had set her up she comes into
charity:water early like crappy office
pause the story Thanks Oh Felix Felix
Felix it's Gary Vaynerchuk you're on the
askgaryvee show can you do me one favor
I'm gonna let Scott finish this Marissa
Mayer story and then we're gonna ask
your question see us oh I got it you ask
how I got into it so it was it was
Michael birch she gets introduced to me
walks in the office you know I'm doing
my thing on the laptop and you know
clicking through all the photos
I just come back from Liberia she
sponsors a couple water projects and
says hey you need to be a pet I'll
sponsor you
so she sponsors me at Ted this is back
in Monterey California
I go someone at the bar that night said
hey there's this guy named Chris Sacca
that's there he's really important for
you I believe can you get him if you can
get him to care about your thing you
know that'll open up a lot of great
connections he was at Google then so I
had the PSA that we've made with
Jennifer Connelly and her kids
directed by Hotel Rwanda Terry George I
had it on iPod Touch walk up the Sokka
tap him on the back and ask him to put
headphones on at the bar at Ted and
watch my PSA and I think he just did so
he watches this thing for 60 seconds the
next thing I know he's trying to get Ted
to play it makes the introduction to
YouTube next thing we know we have the
homepage of YouTube back meant to debut
the PSA tens of millions of views right
we leverage that to get a million-dollar
spot on American Idol to run the
60-second PSA this all happens you know
from clicking on a laptop with the right
person to the next place to the next
place I mean I can draw you know the web
of connections and you know sock has
been to the fields twice now it's how we
met it's how we met right that's why I'm
sitting here is through you know I guess
rewinding that I I believe in that [ __ ]
the most Felix hello you're on the ask
can you feel it with Scott Harrison my
heart is about to jump out in my chest
it's no worries brother what's your
question so my question is I put an
email how do you find your purpose
without getting sucked into fake
ideologies hmm and and I thought was
very interesting I haven't got you know
Scott I had the pleasure of kind of
learning about you on Tom bill you show
impact theory which Jerry just had on
her shows which is all very interesting
that kind of led us to this point I know
expectation to for you Gary to call me
but dad's the question I help on that
anymore about ideology unless you know
what it means I have a sense but ya know
some quick contact
a little audio myself so you know I you
know flat I was just gonna say I don't
think I'm an entrepreneur I don't think
I had that in me I'm working for a
software company right now but I have
looked to expand my horizon pick up new
skills I'm trying to teach myself
photography to teach myself videography
and with really the intent of knowing
that someday that I want to hopefully
impact somebody in a way where they feel
better about themselves I'm on my own
journey where I'm figuring out myself
trying to gain perspective on my life
figure out what it is that makes me
happy what is makes me motivated and
going through this process I do have
been stuck auditing myself quite a while
and one thing that I come to realize is
that I am crippled really by the idea of
other people's pain of me
and have grown up through my life with
that crippling fact about myself so in
this process of saying I wanted you know
impact people make people's lives better
I want to try to figure out if this what
I actually want to do and not just what
I want to do in a sense where other
people would like me because of it if
that make sense very self-aware you've
been you know either listen I want a
self as she think that you've been
paying attention to a lot of my content
because that is one great wrap-up of the
enormous amount of content that I've
been putting out for the last nine
months and it's about you I've watched
you for a Q and a half years Gary I
literally wake up and please keep your
voice listen bro you can't you don't
know what I just felt like it's back to
giving like to hear a young man
articulate that statement I'm quite
aware of how much pressure you know a
lot of people want to think that the
only thing I'm putting out there is
hustle I am putting out a ton of content
that speaks to happiness and an actually
mental health through self-awareness and
more importantly this whole keeping up
with the Joneses or aka needing to be
liked and finding the balance of that
bro you nailed it let me tell you one
thing though
Tom on episode 299 to make this full
circle look me dead in the face and said
your superpowers you don't judge
yourself and he's not wrong
your superpowers you don't judge
yourself you're right that became very
clear to me and I know that's amazing by
the way you know and you know what else
not judging yourself does you don't
judge other people either and I think
what I'm trying to tell you is back to
the way that Scott has done such a great
job in the lexicon it's again very meta
of saying don't say give back say give
I'm gonna tell you something if you're
doing something nice for somebody else
if you're giving I am telling you right
now as somebody who's in your ear
morning and night for the last two and a
half years please hear this and repeat
it and we'll send the clip to you if
you're doing something nice don't judge
yourself if you're doing that for
selfish reasons it's a hell of a lot
better to try to become liked because
you're helping another human then
because you bought Gucci loafers like at
some level we have to stop judging
ourselves and in the actual action of
doing the right thing I you know I like
to always say doing the right thing is
the right thing and everyone you know
that's what this is brother like you're
a young dude I can tell you right now
that Scott and I are blown away about
things we've discovered about ourselves
over the last three years as men that
are pretty self-aware and like to think
about this [ __ ] and are pretty in tune
I'm baffled by my ability to continue to
turn new stones every day how old are
you 45 rather you're gonna keep learning
about yourself all the time
but please please let this little rant
allow you to not judge yourself of why
you want to give if you want to posture
into society that you're a good person
or you're part of a cause but you
actually execute then you're doing the
right thing to me where it gets
dangerous is the following and you've
heard me say this if you're a keyboard
warrior and you put out an Instagram
post of like Big Ups to the people
fighting the fires in California but you
don't have the ability to write a $25
check or to send some water to somebody
or make a phone call if you don't do
something tangible to the keyboard
warrior Ness tweet hashtag me too but
you do nothing about it or in
real life you're actually a douchebag to
the female race that if you're a
hypocrite then your posturing but if
you're actually doing something if you
go this thanksgiving and take mashed
potatoes and put them in somebody's
plate or if you go with 13 bucks and buy
a toy at the dollar store and drop it
off in the lobby of your you know like
all these little things that I act on
that I think about that are subtle there
is no content around it but it's in my
constant motion of doing not speaking to
doing if you're actually giving brother
who gives a [ __ ] if people think you're
good because of it you're actually doing
stop judging yourself I really
appreciate that does that make sense no
no that that make that make and I'm
gonna go very narrow here because it's
more for my audience knowing that you've
figured out what the [ __ ] I've been
saying about keeping up with the Joneses
there's a big difference bro between the
Mercedes and the watch and getting
people to like you and that's the
insecurity versus you going and doing
something that gives value to another
human being you're using one one you're
making an impact the other you're
creating a vulnerability got it
and I love how you thoughtfully put them
together cuz you're right it's my
biggest aha you want you know what
brother I'm gonna honor you by being so
thoughtful with your question let me
tell you the worst thing that ever
happened to me
when Scott changed the course of my life
by inspiring me to be actively good in a
different way than I thought about it in
the past I was always a good guy
I would always help I the amount of
people that owe me money is absurd I
think I could buy the Jets with the io
u--'s I always did a lot of good things
but I never thought about it as macro I
was very immigrant family like you know
you did it for like your cousin or an
employee
it was very insular mmm the biggest [ __ ]
of my life and I say this sometimes but
it's fun to say what Scott here is when
I figured out that there are certain
people in the well group there are
certain people at pencils of promises
board there's certain people at all the
other good things that I've done in my
life and why they're really there is to
paint a picture of themselves to other
powerful people so they can use that
leverage to make money in the outside
world
broke my heart hmm intent matters yeah I
think so
you know but let me say something let me
just finish in German but back to the
advice I gave you still the action of
doing good because there's a lot of
other ways to posture in front of
important people that don't need you to
spend four hours that you know I don't
you know an off site for a board and
thinking that nature the action of good
is always good and I would eliminate
that judgment my guy just what you were
saying I mean you know again if the
vision is to reinvent charity charity
means love charity means to help your
neighbor in need getting nothing in
return not status in return not you know
financial wins for your business it's
it's it's it's a it's like a pure act
Caritas in Latin I know I know I
remember the last time I took but but if
a tower gala is one of the things early
on we did what everybody else did ten
years ago we would sell the product and
bag for five grand we would sell the
week in Telluride the $25,000 cube low
watch and I realize like we were we were
doing the wrong thing this wasn't pure
charity it also wasn't working because
we had people want to buy side of their
brain you would look at that $25,000
watch and be like I never paid 25 for
that I know a guy who blow I'd pay five
or ten or right I would never paid that
for a weekend in Telluride so
everybody's dealing so I ten years ago
we just said we're gonna give people
nothing they're gonna come into our gala
we're gonna give him an opportunity to
be the most generous version of
themselves I actually say that from
stage now I'm so intentional about this
language you are coming and you're gonna
leave with nothing
you're gonna leave you know with nothing
except the fact that you know you used
your resources to end needless suffering
and and to the degree that you use those
resources and and you're gonna go home
and your wife or your husband or your
partner you know it's gonna look at you
hopefully with with respect and
admiration because you did it for the
right reasons the minute we did that I
remember the first year we did away with
a crap that we doubled the race we
literally doubled it last year we raised
4.6 million dollars we fed people a
chicken dinner
like a rubber chicken dinner almost 400
people there were people that just
responded to the stories you know we
were trying to call forth like the
greatest goodness in them and then
believe that they would be transformed
through that unselfish act of giving and
and that that would you know create the
desire to do more they would almost get
addicted to that unselfishness and say
wow actually feels better like think
about it if you're giving because you
care and not giving with an ulterior
motive you sleep better at night you
just do like you just do you you gave
because you you you wanted to respond
you looked at a problem and said I have
the resources to solve that you know a
little bit of that so I would yeah I
think I would encourage you to you know
make sure your your giving you know
follow this pursue Koller n-- video go
learn photographs go go learn how to
tell stories that it sounds like tell
stories that honor people and boast
maybe elevate their conditioner and
you'll find yourself hopefully just
really engaged in the redemptive pure
aspect of that work that you'll just
want to do more of it and oh by the way
for everybody who's watching and be
selfish to what makes you happy to like
it you know I always say to people like
the reason I feel I can give so much is
because my selflessness comes from my
selfishness like like I think one of the
things that people have to understand
it's like you know there's easy ways to
compartment all this stuff like it's
okay to buy yourself a fancy to Y in you
know vacation if that's what you and
your partner want like I feel like
people are play within your own
framework there is no right way guess
what maybe I don't know barter doing
this is just an amazing thing I love my
job that's exact travel around by the
way and by the way just to make this
whole you know wrap some of these things
for the themes of tonight by the way go
spend 18 years building a great business
if that's what makes you happy and then
sell it and my way don't give away 99%
give away 5% give away 1% by the way
look I think that what people want
what's so important right now to me more
than ever is eliminating judgment you
know people give in many different ways
listen I give away like listen there's
organizations and individuals that I
give more of my time to there's places
where I give
my money too like I'm not gonna be I'm
not gonna feel crippled by anybody they
don't know
first well nobody knows I don't know 99%
about Scott what happens in his bedroom
in his head and on a flight when he's by
himself and we're always a bro we're
good Scott how different I mean this is
just a load of question how different of
a man are you today than you were when
you were 25 years old yeah I was a
scumbag at 25
that's degenerate right 25 I was
addicted to cocaine gambling alcohol
strip clubs and pornography and about
two to three packs of Marlboro Reds a
day so he's watching right now and I'm
worried about being too ideological or I
holy [ __ ] feeling pressure like I'm a
bad person like why did I buy a Nintendo
Wii last night I should have given it to
the kids life is long eliminate yourself
first and your past does not dictate
your future that was really the point of
writing the book was the book starts
with me doing drugs and falling through
a plate-glass window at NYU like off my
face to then go to the emergency room
you know get all fixed up and then go
work at Twila he has some club like back
in the day and you know if you had ever
seen the wreck of a human being that I
was this is never someone that's gonna
start a charity this is never someone
that's gonna have a healthy marriage and
kids like this is never someone that's
gonna do and leave any purpose or lead a
life with purpose my tombstone was
actually gonna rule had you met me at 25
my tombstone was going to read here lies
you know a guy who died prematurely
young of a drug overdose and managed to
get millions of people wasted before he
died as a nightclub promoter you know
and now at 43 like my tombstone is
something I think about every day and
guess what you could crush it and you're
the most noble [ __ ] of all time
247 and then you're not finished badly
exactly and I think about finishing well
all the time as you should especially if
you've ever had not good you know if
you've had not good and now you're in
the good zone and we have kids too we
start thinking about the you know the
men we want to be for our children
that's why deep conversations lately of
people that feel in a trap of nobleness
because of their parents but don't feel
accountable to their kids and I have the
craziest combo I've ever had somebody
tell it I'm sorry I'm like I'm just I
couldn't believe this somebody telling
me that they couldn't wait for their
parents to die so they could have some
fun and just a whole like like
everybody's living different lives just
I think have any practical advice on
getting rid of that poison well look I
think you're doing it right now brother
I think one of the quickest ways to get
out poison is to over communicate and
expose yourself
that's what Scott did how many you know
you know how many people are pumped
about talking about being addicted to
pornography cocaine like like I think
you really know to help people in the
honesty like and it helped you too bro
does it trouble you bro like look it was
a bro listen what happened with me you
want to know why I'm here in front of
10,000 people on stage do you know why I
became the entrepreneurs entrepreneur
let me let me give you the preview in
two thousand six seven eight nine ten
when it wasn't as cool to go to Mount
Ida College and get these and F's and
like all that when everybody judged me
cuz they all went to Georgetown and Yale
and all this in my circle of all the
Silicon Valley winners I kept doing it
because it was my truth it was
liberating it was the truth and then the
market moved in a way that made it more
acceptable what would I do if I were you
I go on Instagram right now and make a
video and tell every [ __ ] secret
insecurity you've got just completely
let it go it might feel safe in this
environment right here put it in every
circle of your life it will it will lose
its leverage right our secrets of our
insecurities are the jails of our
emotions the way to free it up is to put
it out in the wild I've very deep
friends and family right now that I wish
they make one 60-second video on
Instagram and tell the world the truth
that the one thing they've been holding
they wouldn't unbeliev how light they
would feel the next day yeah I planned
that's that was this process for me as
well thanks for calling hey first of all
through watching please it would mean a
lot to me you know it would mean a lot
to me if you supported this book they
should read the story be it's the kind
of book
that like lays around on your coffee
table in your dorm room you know in your
vacation home at your office that
somebody else picks up and it becomes
one of those serendipitous stories for
some real reason you Airbnb tout your
house you think that on the things
somebody are hearing those stories
already yeah so that wouldn't mean a lot
a lot to me I think you know one of the
reasons I like to give give give and
then occasionally ask is it gives you
the leverage to come through and look
this is a very important week for me
I've been working secretly on a wine
project for a long time and I'm gonna
ask a whole lot but if you ask me the
truth in my soul I'd rather you buy this
book than the project and so that would
mean a lot to me any final thoughts I'm
just grateful grateful for you and a
long journey it has and we have any
[ __ ] started like I mean it I
actually feel like we're at the
beginning I just like the being I say
that now I feel like getting molarity
the best is yet to come
hi little Estes I had a premonition
right now that the new OTT which is the
new cable which is the new network you
and I are sitting and doing something as
68 year old first weirdly we both look
great
second second I think we have so much in
my history switching 43 what did you
turn 43 September 7th god that's right
you're two months older me I turn 43 in
two days for me for me when you were 25
you were doing what you said at 25 I
spent every hour in a liquor store in
Springfield New Jersey and 18 years
later here both we are making impacts in
our different ways that matter to the
zeitgeist today and guess what in 18
years or only 61 hmm young as [ __ ] I
believe that so many that you know 61
like almost every 61 year-old I know is
doing things that matter right now like
young and with modern medicine and the
way we're taking care of ourselves it's
it's gonna be an amazing journey and I'm
so appreciative that we cross paths
brother I'm so proud of you you don't
even know thanks for being on the show
lovers love you more you keep asking
questions we'll keep answering them
[Music]